اداء رائع لاسود الاطلس في كاس العالم
اسعد الجماهير وابتسموا جميعا لكن هناك
ابتسامات تلقائيه التقطتها عدسات الكاميرا
وبدات معها قصه مشجعا مغربي محمد الشرفي
تعرض لموجه تنمر عقب ظهوره على شاشات
التلفاز من مدرجات ملعب البيت في قطر وهو
يشجع منتخب بلاده امام كرواتيا وذلك بسبب
شكل السنه
فئه المتنمرين هذه كتبوا تعليقات ساخره
معتبرين ان المبلغ الذي وفره للذهاب لقطر
كان الاولى به اصلاح شكل الاسنان وقبل
السفر والتفكير في السفر على الجانب الاخر
ظهرت موجات والتضامن كبيره مع الشر في ردا
على هؤلاء المتنمرين كان من بينهم طبيب
الاسنان شهد الشيخ الذي اطلق حمله للتعرف
على هذا المشجع معلنا اعتبر العرض بسرعه
اجمل ابتسامه للمشجع المغربي اتعرف على
المشجع محمد الشرطيب شادي الشيخ في حلقه
اليوم
[موسيقى]
الرياض الرياض
وقفل الفيديو ينضم الينا طبيب الاسنان
دكتور شادي الشيخ والمشجع المغربي محمد
الشرف في دكتور شادي محمد
معنا
حضورك منتخب مباراه قطر
الاماراتي واا بالنسبه الي كان يعني شعور
كاس العالم خلق عروبيه حلوه يعني احنا في
الاردن كنا نشجع السعوديه ونشجع المغرب
تونس
انا شفت صراحه صورته في المباراه اتوقع
المغرب
للامانه قبل ما اسمع عن التنمر قبل شيء
مجرد ما شفته شيء في داخليه يعني قال لي
انا انا كنت حاب اعمل له سناب همم وبعد ما
صارت التنمر بتذكر قرات ما قال واحد فقط
يعني انا ما قرات ال- همم موجه من التنمر
ما اخذ مني قرار تقريبا 10 ثواني يمكن
كتبت عندي على الانستغرام اللي بيعرف همم
رقم هاتفه بس يبلغني فيه هذا كان السؤال
الوحيد خلال 15 دقيقه
عبر الواتساب والهاتف وقلت له انا جاي
اخذك ان شاء الله وتجيء معي يهون على دبي
تعمل اسنانك في عياد دبي محمد كيف كان
شعورك
دوله الامارات واشكر دوله قطر
الدكتور
لما اتصل اتصل بي 30 دكتور
كل واحد من
واشكرهم جميعا وكل واحد اختصاصاته لكن كان
الافضل هو شادي وما شاء الله عليه يعني
طبيب جراح جميل جدا او انا اشكرهم هذا من
القناه العربيه همم
شكرا
لجميع
واعتني قوه وانا الحمد لله همم في همم قوه
الان لما كنت في دار لما شاهدت
فرحان في المباراه المنتخب
فيها ضغط مواقع التواصل يا محمد في ناس
فعلا تمروا وفي ناس كثير دفعوا عنك كيف
انت شفت التفاعل والحمد لله اشكر الناس
الذي همم يعني دافع عني وتم يعرفوني جيدا
انا مغربي يعني اصيل
غيرها على الوطن غير على
البلد الحمد لله ده خير بمناسبه لي طيب
دكتور شادي
بالتحمل تكاليف سفر محمد من قطر الى
الامارات وتحمل كذلك تكاليف صناعه اسنانه
حدثنا اكثر عن الموضوع والله الصراحه همم
يعني اكيد هذا شيء يعني بسيط يعني انت
مجرد ما تسمعي حدا يتنمر على حدا ترى
التنمر مش بس على الاسنان ممكن على اشياء
كثير لكن الاسنان بدها حتى مرات الاطفال
بتنمر عليهم
انا الاول ما قبلته كان حزين وزعلان
الموضوع اكثر عليه يعني وعلى قلبه لما
جلست معه يعني همم حسيت بقديش هو فعلا زعل
وحزن من كل اعماق قلبه انه يسمع الناس او
يقرا الناس هيك تتكلم منه والله كل كل
انسان عنده ظروف واذا تسمح لي بس اخبرهم
هو ما في اسنان يصلحها المشكله كانت تنمر
بسبب بشكل اسنان هو فاقد الاسنان وما في
الا اربعه اسنان حتى حتى الاجزاء العظميه
يعني هو بحاجه ايضا للزراعه عظم طيب هنا
بدي اسال محمد محمد انت قلت للناس تنمر
عليك قالوا ليش يروح مباراه في قطر هو مش
قادر يدفع صناعه اسنانه قلت عند كان عندك
مشكله في القلب مناعتك من صناعه اسنانك هل
هذا فعلا حصل
الحمد لله
عندي مشكله في العظام
عندي في العظام يعني نقص شويه في العظام
والحمد لله الدكتور يتكلم همم
تؤثر على محمد همم
اول اول سؤال س بعد ثالث كلمه مع التليفون
عندك سكري اتاكد انه ما عنده امراض ما ما
في امراض بالقلب ما باخذ اي ادويه فهو
الحمد لله انسان رياضي ما بيدخن ما بارجل
فهو انسان مناسب لعمل الزراعه بنسبه نجاح
الزراعه بين ال 97 الى 99% زراعه الاسنان
او زراعه العظم بالنسبه له لكن هو بحاجه
تقريبا الى زراعه عظم في ثلاث اماكن او
اربع اماكن تاخذ من اربعه على سته اشهر
وبحاجه كمان همم زراعه اسنان همم
بدها همم يعني نفس طويل لحاله ان شاء الله
بكره هيستلم شيء مؤقت يكون معه والصوره
اللي كانت منتشره انه مركب اسنانه كانت
فوتوشوب مش همم مش حقيقيه من حدهم تصور مع
احد مشجعين وحط له هذه انتشرت لكن الى
الان انا ما عملت له اسنانه اليوم هيكون
نبلش اليوم شيء مؤقت ممكن تشوفه صوره حلوه
جميله
جميله ان شاء الله
اولادي في المغرب متحمسين وعائلتي
واشكر الجميع همم الذي انضم الي واشكر همم
يعني اود اشكر العالم كله انا شايفتك جميل
حتى بروحك يا محمد يعني انت انشهرت كا
يعني مشجع مغربي مشهور تكون مباريات
المغرب حتى ابنك الريال 2019
خلاص عفو عنهم الشعور ريان شجعته انه تعمل
اسنانك
تكلم مع الدكتور واجبه الحال يعني
كثير كثير يعني ما بقول لك فرحه لا توصف
حتى بنتي في المغرب
قصدي
رجعت ابتسامتك ولا امبارح كلمتها الدكتور
قالت شكرا حتى يرجع ابتسام لابي اللي كانت
من زمان
والمغرب الان يمثل في كاس العالم جميع
العرب جميع الدول العربيه والاسلاميه نحن
وطن واحد الحمد لله فرق بيننا المغرب
والامارات وقطر وسوداني وجزائري وتونسي
حمزه كلنا جسد واحد طيب محمد في مباراه
منتظره يعني المغرب تاهل الدور الثماني
مباراه المتوقعه مع اسبانيا هترجع القطر
تشجعوا وتعود وبيت ان شاء الله الله نحييك
على حماس
ان شاء الله يوم الاثنين
تعرف
ين
الجو والجو حار
وتلوث
من هذا المنبر
الموضوع ابدا ما له دخل انه تكلفه ابدا
وانا قابلته مش بفندق حتى يعني اليوم كنت
بقرا التنمر عليه بموضوع الاسنان انه
متكلف نفسه فاحيانا الذي يمنعك من عمل
اسنانك ليس المال صح
لو لقيت نمبر وما تخاف عليهم تنمروا
بسهوله شكرا